pourquoi tu veux participer à l'émission
faut essayer la première place sous les
feux des projecteurs les aficionsados du
programme M6 La France a un incroyable
talent avait rendez-vous à plaisir ce
samedi 1er juillet chant humour ou
magique 80 candidats étaient venus faire
face à un membre du jury dans le centre
eau shopping grand plaisir objectif
décrocher sa place sur le petit écran
nos visiteurs les territoires puisque on
donne la possibilité à nos clients des
alentours de venir
exprimer leurs talents sur scène
[Musique]
être une personne unique cet auteur
compositrice originaire des Yvelines
était venu présenter son univers gospel
urbain l'espoir d'une belle exposition
médiatique pour cette jeune artiste de
21 ans il y a toujours un petit stress
enfin un grand stress d'ailleurs quand
il y a autant de personnes et quand on
voit les enjeux mais j'ai vraiment
apprécié l'idéal ce serait effectivement
de gagner après les cent mille euros je
les vois pas comme un gain je les vois
vraiment comme un investissement futur
on regarde tout le temps donc on a
profité de l'occasion qu'un incroyable
talent le casting soit là pour venir
regarder il y avait du bon niveau dans
les champs sur cette journée deux
candidats ont été sélectionnés pour
passer le prochain casting avec la
production du programme un nouveau
rendez-vous avant d'espérer passer à la
télévision